Here we go.
We are recording. Welcome to another Zoom call.
We have a number of questions to get through and then we'll open it up for your chat. So let's get started.
First, some reminders. Remember that if you do have questions about something, always go to the website first.
And do a search in this little thing where the arrow is pointed to any page of the website. You can do that search like that. And you can see.
Ask a question. So.
And we may have made a blog post about it at some point of time. So if you have a question about different things like.
Does he has you ever talked and talked about, you know, whatever you could, you could at least get some ideas if we made a video if I've made a blog post or something like that that could be helpful for you.
All right, let's get to some questions. We are initiated a gradual deck of drawn decks of methods own weed. So this person who's writing this question is weeded off of anti inflammatory steroid.
What rife programs should we run for this? Well, there isn't any specific rife programs to help you weed off of something, but.
I understand the mechanism of action of the drug that you can try to do some rife programs that will help support what that drug was trying to do. In this case, this is an anti inflammatory.
So running some swelling programs, some anti employment. I think there's an inflammation program and a swelling program on the right. Those are two things that you could run.
If is can have some benefits for swelling and inflammation, but that's not the key component of the rife is swelling and inflammation. So there's some limitations to the rife. It's a tool you have to use it the right way.
It's not going to be a great tool for decreasing inflammation.
So this could we do to support this? Well, that's the next question. What else could you do? Well, opine anti inflammatory nutrients like curcumin, resveratrol, EGCG from green tea extract white willow bark, stingy dental.
Yeah, things like that.
Cercetin.
Even an acetyl cystine can help a little bit the vitamin.
The total the delta total tree dolls from vitamin E member vitamin E has four inner components and four outer components, the outer components are the to cough or all the inner components are the total tree dolls that delta.
The dietary and all can be anti inflammatory can reduce inflammation in.
In cytokine formation that can be helpful as well. So things like that.
Other tools that can be helpful to decrease inflammation coffee animals can be very helpful to decrease inflammation anything that you can do to support parasympathetic function.
So back to the blog post.
Let me pull it up real quick. The blog post new parasympathetic toad would be beneficial. So.
Let me grab it.
It's if you just go again to that search bar and you search sympathetic or parasympathetic.
And you'll see, you'll see a blog post on sympathetic parasympathetic tone.
And it will be look like that at the top.
And that has a video to talk about different things that you could do to stimulate parasympathetics on that blog post also you have two different PDFs that you could download one on reducing sympathetic tone, one on increasing parasympathetic tone.
And it details on that I've talked about that on a lot of the calls that you can watch that video.
So anything you can do to decrease sympathetic and increase parasympathetics are going to be helpful to decrease inflammation.
We are running the 18 minute adrenal program one to three times a day.
That's good to that will help. So you want to decrease inflammation. You want to stimulate just a good balance of.
It's a hormone function. So the other thing you can think of is adaptogens.
So adaptogenic herbs.
And adaptogenic mushrooms can be very beneficial to.
Next, I was wondering about being able to have an evening drink with my wife, we used to have a drink together, which hasn't happened very often at all.
vodka came up as a possibility. I think vodka's made for potatoes. Can you share any thoughts about that.
So alcohol and cancer. That's the real question. How much alcohol can a person drink?
Where it starts to become bad for them. Well, there's there's some it really partly it depends.
I don't know who was asked this question, but it depends on partly on what type of cancer you have.
One blanket answer would be, you should stay away from alcohol completely. One of the reasons that you could arguments that you could make for that is that alcohol is going to tax your liver.
And if you don't have a better what type of cancer you have, if you're going to drink alcohol, you're going to take up a lot of side of growth, the P450 energy to get rid of the alcohol alcohol converts to an aldehyde and you have to, it takes a lot of energy in your liver.
So, is that a wise thing to do when you're dealing with a serious disease and you could argue that it's not necessarily wise thing to do, even if you're not dealing with serious disease, because that can end up being a factor and you getting a serious disease is the fact that you have taxed your liver.
You put stress on your liver, you took up energy from detox pathways that now you can't detox the heavy metals that you were exposed to or the other toxins that you were exposed to and that settles in the cells and that's the cause of a future cancer.
Maybe you never would have had that settle in the cells, you would have been able to detoxify it if you weren't taking up energy from these detox pathways to deal with alcohol that you're dealing with.
It's about our conversation is that for people who like alcohol, well, but that's the truth of it, it gets worse if you have any inflammation of the brain, so if you have had chemotherapy, so you already have some damage to microglial cells.
In the brain, then alcohol is an absolute no no, it just helps with all the studies with microglial primate that's damaged to the to specific brain cells.
Alcohol across the board was a major player in causing increase inflammation of primed microglial cells.
It's just people that have any type of brain inflammation from either they did chemotherapy, they had a brain tumor or they had concussions post concussive syndrome, even if you're 60 years old and you had concussions when you're a teenager, you really need to stay away from alcohol.
There's a lot of dialed sites, so it's like gosh, this is okay, he's really busted my balloon here, but it's is there a balance in all of this, so I'm telling you all the negatives of alcohol, but is there a balance of this well yeah you have to find that balance.
Drinking one vodka tonic a night, I think is way out of balance so that's not to be a balance if you're going to drink a couple of drinks of vodka a couple vodka tonics a month maybe that would be a balance.
Well, how about wide, wide is different, wide is a lower alcohol content that you know 80 proof vodka it's only 12 proof or whatever in wine, so it has a lower alcohol content, well that's true, so it is going to do last damage on your liver, so could you have a glass of wide a night.
Maybe again you're taking up energy from your liver detox pathway, so maybe I would say maybe a couple glasses of wine a week would be maximum.
And again, if you have any inflammation and any evidence of prime microglial cells, I would say that you can't do that at all.
And if you have questions about what I just said about prime microglial cells go to the website again in this section right here search for.
I think that's what I have a video on prime microglial cells what that is and I think it's under neuro inflammation and it's a 30 minute video and it explains what I just said there in detail as far as anatomical physiological function of what's takes place in your brain.
And alcohol compounds that greatly so.
I just made one of these there but sorry.
Next, how much of your foot should be underwater in the foot bath you want to get as much of your foot underwater so how much water should you put in there you want to fill it up.
About you know so that it's a few inches from the top so that you can actually pick it up without spilling it while you're going to the sink.
So, but you want to get your foot in there so that you have enough surface area that is underwater that's getting benefit.
The next in my mind or it says can I eat various that I can eat various types of meat except poultry so that's just what tested for you so that how much meat is recommended so.
So we typically don't recommend that you eat meat unless you know that you do better so let's say even if a person tests that we're testing forward we're testing foods we're testing for any foods that are driving the cancer or feeding the cancer so.
If if in this case you can eat various types of meat except poultry then.
You hold up the stuff video there so you can't eat poultry so that means you could eat red meat or you could eat fish is that mean you should or you have to know it doesn't it means that those things are not driving the cancer.
Some people do better not eating any meat or hardly at all they might eat it only eat it once a week some people feel horrible if they only eat meat once a week they need to eat it every day that has to do with your body type.
How your methionine pathway what methionine pathway how well you're breaking down B12 components how well you absorb B12 there's other things that are that are in that mix not just what's feeding the cancer so everybody's different that way so in your case if it says.
That you can eat various types of meat except poultry how much meat is recommended we're not recommending how much meat it has to do with your energy level if you do really well and you feel like your energy is really good and boy I eat only fish I haven't had any red meat and I haven't had any.
Poor and I only eat fish once every couple weeks my energy is up and pretty doing really good then just stick to that so but if you're there's other people that boy if they don't eat some meat a little bit every day that they're down in the depths that they need to do that.
Everyone else says that animal protein feeds cancer so I kind of address that when we're testing for we're testing for what is fueling the cancer so no this is a wrong statement I don't care what everybody else says I mean it might be right I'm just saying my opinion is animal protein does not always feed cancer we are meant to be.
Of course and but we don't want to be fueling the cancer so with some people we tested they're not on any meat and a lot of people that meat is not feeding their cancer something else is feeding their cancer and they can eat meat and they feel very horrible if they don't eat meat so.
Cancer is different with everybody and cancers fuel source can change in a given person as well so when we test you this is why we should do follow up.
Cheekswap test because your cancer can change its fuel source so if you're an original testing it says you can eat everything except poultry.
We can test you again in three months and now you can eat pork or poultry something like that it can change your body the cancer is trying to bite a fuel source all the time so you have to be.
fluid and moldable what you're dealing with cancer because things can change will you tip capsule so you is a is a evergreen shrub.
That grows in multiple different areas of climates and it is becoming a more popular nutritional nutraceutical and it can be a good immune stimulant so it's in the family of.
What's that other evergreen that is I can't remember I'll think of it in a minute but it's becoming a more popular nutraceutical can it interfere with black sap no I I'm not heard that it interferes black sap at all so no I would say you could take it all right along with black sap my doctor questions it's the use.
Kibo like action will suppress my immune response no no because it's because it actually is an immune stimulant so I don't believe that's true at all.
The blacks have needs the immune response to exteriorize the tumor so no you can I it's not an immune suppressant and it's not and it's not an oxidizing agent like Kibo is.
It's not it doesn't damage your immune cells so you could do it at the same time.
What do you consider histamine foods so this is a good question to go right back to the block here so you go right back to the.
website search for histamine foods I've written.
Six or seven articles on histamine foods and what are the things that you'll find is an article says low histamine diet the high histamine food list so that gives you a list of all those foods in that histamine diet there's a whole 30 histamine food list in there too whatever you're trying to decrease histamine which all of us probably should try to decrease histamine.
And our foods it's just that it's trying to decrease histamines you cannot eliminate histamines in your food it's impossible there it's basically histamines are just about anything and if they're not in something if you put that thing in their refrigerator a couple days they will be in you all have histamines in that thing it's not a matter of eliminating histamine it's just reducing the histamine.
Loan on your body histamine builds up in the person's body and you have specific genes which help digest histamines in your gut those are your DAO genes and it's made by a.
That enzyme is made by the D I DAO gene and it's called the DAO enzyme you also have that enzyme made by a different gene in the tissues your H and empty gene.
makes it in the tissues to decrease histamines in your tissues so decreasing histamines in your diet is to try to take away take down the histamine load histamine is inflammatory molecules taking down that histamine and inflammation in the gutter that could be very helpful most people.
Probably he too many histamines because of damage guts we have even if you have very little defects on your DAO genes you probably don't.
Breakout histamines as well because of the damage of everybody's guts because of GMO foods especially and so reducing your histamine load would be good for everyone.
One could make an argument about but look at you'll see that whole histamine diet that also if you were told to go on a low histamine diet your liaison probably sent you that whole 30 diet already so look at your email box as well.
Can you talk about proteolytic enzymes especially seropeptidase so proteolytic enzymes so enzymes are made by proteins.
They are a protein they're made by your body different parts of your body your pancreas makes a lot of your digestive enzymes proteolytic means they break down
lytic breaks down proteins proteins so proteolytic enzymes as an enzyme that breaks down proteins a lot of enzymes do break down proteins you do have enzymes that break down fats those are called lipases.
And you have proteins that break down starches called amulases so there's different types of enzymes but seropeptidase is one of the enzymes that is can be very anti inflammatory can also help reduce pain
and swelling it can be very beneficial for the gut it can be very beneficial for the respiratory tract for bronchitis and chronic lung issues and chronic respiratory and asthma issues it's even said to be good for blood clots but lumbarol kinases a much better enzyme for blood
clots clots and nanokinase but seropeptidase is a great enzyme for a lot of things of course I'm very big on all the enzymes so I really like the different mixed enzymes from US enzymes and those are probably one of my favorite
enzymes because they are so clean in their production that company is in their enzyme production so you get a really good quality enzyme but they actually
make a lot of enzymes for a lot of other nutritional products too so if you're using an enzyme it might actually be made by US enzymes
so but so seropeptidase is an enzyme that can be beneficial for all those things so enzymes can be extremely
beneficial if people think of them as just oh they'll help me digest my food but they do more than that so
especially if you take enzymes on an empty stomach you will absorb more of them so they'll do less work because
there's going to be less work to do in the gut itself and you'll absorb those enzymes that they have
action systemically so they can help with your bloodstream they can help with your tissues
Dr. William Kelly's enzyme therapy for cancer is taking high doses of enzymes to help to
so that you absorb them on an empty stomach of course or you absorb them and they help break down the
cancer now every single one of our patients has been tested for enzyme therapy if we don't have you on
a fairly high dose enzyme then you didn't test for that but enzymes even if you don't test for it can be
really good for a lot of things and remember just because you have cancer this is what we're testing
to you for when you were doing the cheek swab and stuff doesn't mean you don't have other conditions too
so there can be you know a good argument that you should be taking supplements for and different
things for other conditions or you should be eating right just like good going back to the question
about food and should I be eating meat how much I eat and I heard animal protein is not good for you
well some people don't do well on animal protein they should eat it at all regardless of whether it
feeds their cancer or not so you do want to treat yourself as aesthetically and holistically as
possible so there's times to use that and one of the one of my favorite supplements that I take
every day almost without fail are enzymes so they could have a lot of benefits you know I'm obviously
real big on HCl and digestive enzymes forgot health and digestion but using a digestive plus from
US enzyme I believe that has seropeptic acid but I take personally the lumbarose
enzyme and the natto kinase because I'm very susceptible I don't know if it has something to do with my
genes or not to to the spike protein I don't feel well after I've been around people that have been
vaccinated sorry if you've been vaccinated but so I'm conscious of this that you're right here so
it's the lumbarol kinase of the the natto kinase are better for that and if that's due to that
term is due to you I have a blog post so just search lumbarol kinase up here and I have a blog post
that and you'll be able to see that so if you just start typing it in you'll be able to see the blog
post if you want to next question how many hours between the night and day treatments
I understand when I write these questions down I'm literally copied and pasted from somebody's email
so I'm assuming that that person is saying that they're do they have to is there a recommended
pause between doing my night programs and then should I pause for a period of time if I do my day
programs the answer is no I mean you there you can literally run the rife 24-7 if you want
but the only time we really recommend that for people is if the person's cancer is growing
crazy we do want you to live your life so when I was really when I was at my worst I was running the
rife all day at work and I was running it as soon as I got home in my chair and all night long I was
running the rife so that's how my staff knew I wasn't feeling good because I had my rife running so
they would go oh he's not doing so much today he's got us right Friday during the day so I tend to be
a person that doesn't sit down for a very long when I work at my computer I obviously do but I'm
the kind of person that goes on vacation and drives his wife crazy because we're going to finally sit
out and lay down on the beach and I'll sit down for five minutes and have to get up and walk the
beach and listen to a book on tape or something because I can't stand to sit any longer so but that's
just me and that makes it hard for me to rife when I am what I need to during the day so but there
does not have to be any pause between night and day treatments you can run at 24-7 next is the
grounding mat left on the bed at night so the grounding mat that comes with your rife is specifically
for the foot bath for the iron pro wave that's what it's for it's not for you to use at night
if you're talking if the question that this person they asked you they're not talking about the
grounding mat that came with their true rights they're talking about a grounding sheet that they bought
or a grounding mat at some other distributor or something that they purchased should you have it on your
bed at night so here's my take I know my good true rife has a different philosophy about this but
this is this is my thing my light of thinking so you're running the rife you're running the frequencies
out of this bulb the frequencies are going to be attracted to a ground so if you have a
grounding sheet on your bed my recommendation is that you put the grounded sheet only on the lower
part of the bed so on your buttocks down goes the grounding sheet and why would you do that because
you're not you're holding that rife on your chest you're struggling with it laid on your back let's
say you roll on your side the the rife bulb is laid on your mattress and if you have a grounding
sheet there underneath your fitted sheet you could be losing a lot of the frequencies to the
ground it's to the grounding sheet out the wire into the machine and out the ground into the ground into
the ground so you could be losing a lot of the benefits of the frequencies you want the frequencies
to go through your body otherwise they're not doing anything so it's not helping you so we that people
have asked us that a lot of times how come you don't sell a grounding sheet with your package we do
have grounding sheets if you want to buy one but you only use it on the lower half of your bed
I don't want you using a grounding sheet while you're rifey unless you could be very
conscious about your bulb placement and it's staying you're late I stay on my back all night long and
I don't even move so the bulb I wake up but it's I'm still snuggling with the bulb on my abdomen
then you'd probably be fine with the grounding sheet so but not everybody is like that and not
everybody stays in one position all night long so but if you talk if this question is addressing
the grounding mat that came with your rife from us it should not even be used at night on your bed
it's only used with the foot bath and then how many times do you do the foot bath per week
how many times should you do the foot bath per week everybody's different so there if we programmed
some specific cancer program foot bath programs for you I would say do that a couple times a week
would be good so I've told everybody that has asked me because I'm completely upfront and out of
myself I never do the foot bath is that good no don't do what I do do what I say so I don't do the
foot bath because again I'm too I'm just that's just me I can't sit there and do the foot bath
so it's it's but is it good to do the foot bath yes there's some great benefits to the foot bath you
have this great tool use the foot bath how many times we have some patients that do it every day
um can you do it too many times um yeah you can do anything too many times would it hurt you if
you did it five times a day probably not but you you need you should be living your life not doing
your foot bath five times a day doing the foot bath once a day is probably really should be your maximum
so that should be only if you're really doing poorly and you're not feeling well but if you're
starting to feel well and stuff you need to start focusing on all other things in your life and
to fill in your purpose and not sit either doing your foot bath then doing it every couple a couple
times a week is more appropriate um all right next question on that is our last question that was on
here so start chatting in your questions if you have them here's one that came in what is the
role of Epsom Salt in the liver gall bladder flush so Epsom Salt in the liver gall bladder flush
so the liver gall bladder flush is another tool to help flush out your gall bladder it's a
gall liver gall bladder flush you can see it again on our blog page there's a mild which I always
recommend people start with and that doesn't involve Epsom salts and then there is
more severe gall bladder flush if you want to say that and that is using Epsom salts it just helps
draw a contraction from the gall bladder to help you're trying to get the greatest contraction of
the gall bladder that's what you're usually the Epsom Salt with with the olive oil so you're trying to
get the greatest contraction of the gall bladder so it squeezes out as many of the stones as possible
make sure that isn't the first gall bladder liver gall bladder flush you do make sure you do the mild
one several times before you get to the Epsom Salt one any other questions if you have a question you could
unmute yourself and verbalize your question or you could shout it in what is the
reason for saying that we are not supposed to have bone broth when it also says we're supposed to drink
soups so it depends on the person so bone broth so bone broth is made by boiling bones
for a long period of time whether it be chicken bones or at the beef bones or pork bones you're boiling
it and you're getting the broth from the bones what you're getting from that is you're getting a
very high concentration of glutamine well that's so bone broth is a really great tool to help
heal a person's gut so the epithelial cells that line your small and large intestine
feed off of glutamine very powerfully and it really helps them
multiply and grow and heal glutamine can be a very strong driver for growth
and that's why glutamine is contained in a lot of bone healing supplements so you see some
gut healing GI supplements it contained it can contain anywhere between you know a gram to five
grams of L glutamine and the reason why is it's it's basically a supplement of you know what
will you find in bone broth and it can be very effective and help healing the gut well it heals
the gut because it stimulates growth not just of epithelial cells but strongly of epithelial cells
well if you have cancer glutamine you know even if your cancer is not driven if we tested you
and you could eat meat I still do I still never recommend high glutamine foods or supplements to a
person so the amount of glutamine you forget off of a well-made bone broth is pretty high so you that
wouldn't be something that you'd want to do so bone broth is not something that you'd want to do given
a cancer diagnosis even if when we tested you that meats were okay for you
so you can still make soup without making a strong bone broth so I boiled my chicken for a couple
hours till it fell off the bone but then I did take all the bones off of it and I left the chicken cut
up the chicken and then I added my vegetables and rice or haramay chicken soup that's not a really
strong bone broth so when you talk about making a bone broth drink for a person that has serious
gut issues they're talking about boiling the bone broth or leaving it on a simmer for a couple days
in a crock pot to get all the broth out of that bone you're getting a very high concentrated
glutamine that's where the same thing is using a supplement for gut healing with a high concentration
of glutamine so that's the reason why you wouldn't want to do a bone broth with cancer
maybe a better thing to do is to you know make a soup but instead of boiling the whole chicken or
for boiling it for less time a or number two using just the chicken meat if you're making if chicken
is okay for a person to eat I'm saying that you're going to make chicken soup and chicken breast
and cutting it up and adding just the chicken breast so you're not getting the bone at all
so that your soup is a very low glutamine soup
that's the idea so it's the glutamine content in bone broth you can make vegetable broth that doesn't
have glutamine in it you can make a vegetable soup that wouldn't have any glutamine in it
you can make a chicken soup like I said with fairly low glutamine almost you know very low glutamine
if you're just using the chicken breast and and a little bit higher if you boil the chicken
carcass for a period of time hopefully that answers that back to the chat
caster oil packs instruction say stomach areas can they be placed on the limb area such as the armpits
chest anywhere that feels good answers yes so you can put caster oil packs anywhere the only place
that I would caution you to do it is it doing it right over a breast cancer we've had patients that do
it successfully right over a breast cancer but go slow on that so if you're going to if a person
has a breast cancer and you're going to put a caster oil pack over it don't leave it there for a
long period of time I would just even try five minutes at a time and see now usually we recommend
caster oil packs over the liver so that's on the right side lower ribs and right underneath the ribs
and if you get that right side over the liver that could be one of the most beneficial places for
caster oil packs is it really helps helps pull helps get the liver moving and will really speed
your detoxification pathways you can put it over a limb area as it can help with with limb flow too
so you there's lots of ways that you could use caster oil packs secondly a lot of people are like
I don't know another caster oil packs they're so messy even using hot packs just using hot water
models or using that the low eabeth hot pack that electric hot pack that we have that is
infrared is really good over the liver so if you don't have time to pass with caster oil packs that
you just putting a hot pack over your liver is it can have really great benefits too but yeah you
can move around you can do them at different spots did definitely don't put caster oil in your eye
or anything like that but my doctor recommended that I get my escar biopsy he said the cancer type might
change from zebra to an elephant is that true and can cancer change types after you've already been
diagnosed I know I don't know I don't think so no so the type of cancer a cancer is named by the cell
type that is involved in the tumor itself so and really that's really not gonna change how you're
treating it anyhow um I guess maybe if you were gonna do chemotherapy um possibly I just don't see
that being at all an issue no I why would you do that I just no I don't see that I I had to really talk
to that doctor to see what his thought process is but because I'm not jiving with that and I could be
wrong but I just don't get what he's thinking about there um is the growth concerned with broth
also a reason for not fasting more than 48 hours yes but it's different it's a different chemical
process so the fasting for 48 hours after you fast for more than 48 24 hours sorry after you fast
for more 24 hours your idea of one level score so glutamine um yeah it probably does stimulate
idea of one pathways um so yes they are tied together somewhat metabolically but yes it's the exact
same process that we're talking about here exactly right no matter how well it makes you feel to do
that because of growth hormones yes that's exactly right so if you don't have cancer fast eat more
than 24 hours again you should work up through fasting processes but fasting more than 24 hours can
be very beneficial because it increases IGF1 and IGF1 can be really good for anti-aging can be really
good for cell regeneration because it increases growth of cells and hey it's great to have new cell
growth but you certainly don't want IGF1 poured on the cancer because it's gonna increase cell growth
so um understand how that is so things that you would do this is the heart that you had functional
medicine so things that you would do that would be really good for your heart are not necessarily
really good for cancer so I want to increase my veg F production because it'll increase
vascular endothelial growth factor growth of new vessels in my heart um that's gonna be really good
for that so I'm gonna use high dietary oxides supplements and things like that and different anti-aging
things like that that are really good for your heart uh you don't want to do that for cancer
so you don't want to increase Vegep you do not want to increase IGF1 you do not want to increase
vascularization when you have cancer so some of the things that you would do if you didn't have
cancer for for to help you you know live longer to support uh vascular function different things
these things that you wouldn't do with cancer so you got to be aware of that. Next question
Dr. Cutters what is your opinion on quintons marine plasma and folic acid? I am reading the Bible
and I'll turn it to medicine and uh the doctor who wrote the book highly recommends these they
can be really good I know that the quintons marine plasma uh liquid that is uh know that uh quick
silver carries some um we have we have some in our store it doesn't it hasn't ever tested right and
we have had it for years when they first came out with it it's never tested for people for cancer
it's nothing wrong with it I think it can be good for different things but it's never tested as a
cancer treatment literally never so we've had people buy it I don't even think we have an
stock right now but um we've had people buy it because they read something about it or their doctor
recommend some of their doctor recommended it um and I and I'm sure there's some real good benefits to
help balance your um your electrolytes and such so I think there's can be really good balance
benefits of it but it's for cancer for some reason I was really excited about it we first got it
six or seven years ago but it's just never tested um the folic acid is a totally different story so
folic acid is uh is a fantastic binder um we have it in a lot of products so
folic and humic acid are great products they can be binders that actually you could absorb
they can really help with mold they can help bind heavy metals they're just they're great things
they they have proven to test really well um they're in a lot of different things that we use
um is bovine gelatin similar to bone broth yes it is bovine gelatin has um
has glutamated but it's in fairly low concentration so if there's a bovine gelatin in one of your
capsules of supplements there's not enough even measurable glutamated it but if you're using bovine
gelatin in a food I don't I don't know the concentration if you're using it in a recipe or something
like that so I don't think it's a major concern because I think you have to consume a lot to get the
glutamate out of it so uh next there are some right programs that said to use the grounded mat on the
back or under the foot yes okay for example the ones for back pain so um you kid wisely
use the grounded mat we used to actually sell the rites with this grounded there's on the front of
your receipt I think on the F122's it still has it has a grounded plug that you could plug in a
grounded wand we used to sell a grounded wand with the rites too you then you could strategically
place the wand somewhere um really only worked for like rectal cancer so if you put the the bulb on
your abdominal cavity and you put the wand between your cheeks um you could effectively kind of draw
the frequencies through the body to that that wand and you can if you really think about it use a
grounded sheet and or a grounded pad um wisely um to basically direct the frequencies towards
something so but then you have to be very conscious of that so um let's say I you have breast cancer
could you put the bulb right over your breasts and put the grounded mat behind your back and then lead
back yes you could but then you got to understand too just because you have breast cancer doesn't mean
you don't have circulating tumor cells in your liver or in your brain um you don't want to have
metastasis to those areas so that's why I caution you about using the grounded mat or grounded sheet
or grounded wand when you're using your cancer programs that we have written for you because you
want them to go and disperse is evenly as possible throughout your whole body you don't want them to
necessarily be directed through your body and then out to a grounded pencil where so yes if you're
running different specific frequencies for back pain you can do that that makes sense you're putting
the pad behind your back and you want the frequencies to go right through there right to that area
that makes that makes perfect sense and that could be a good thing but I would caution you about use
you have to be very wise with your use of those things when you're running your your cancer programs
okay good and the other questions okay so um and we got a bunch of people on um I do want to make
an announcement to everybody is that we are moving our clinic so anybody has been to our clinic
you're like what you're moving yes our lease is due and we've been looking forward to the state of our
move for a long period of time um well so we'll have a different mailed address so make sure you call
in and ask for the mailed address if you're mailed in a cheek swab to us now we won't have an issue with
getting it um we actually have this space and have our mailbox through August but we had this
wonderful opportunity to get in this other space and we're excited to get into this other space um so
if you do mail it to this current address we'll still get it we'll be checking our mail daily but we'll
be telling you to mail um any bulk packages or anything else to our new address um so that
I won't be sitting outside or don't work so make sure you call the clinic to get that new address if
you have to mail anything to us um and that will be the nice benefit of getting our membership only
pages done so that we will be able to put up announcements like that on our membership only pages
and to speak about that I said at the beginning of this that we hope to have that it's I really have
them almost completely done but um we're waiting on the HubSpot to get it um fully published
so I'm hoping by next week or the week after for sure we're going to have that up and ready
everybody is going to get a bulk email from us so you will get an email from us
or how to log into that so you'll have a link to get to that membership site that isn't going to be
public though other people could probably find it if they if they searched for or something like that
but it will be a login only site so you'll use your primary email or the one that we will email to you
and you will um then create your own password just like any other site and its password protected
and if you forget your password there'll be a forgot your password button so that you could you could
create a new password so but in there there'll be a whole bunch of videos all the Zoom calls like this
will be on there uh so that you can access them at a later date if you're so desired um in a bunch of
different patient only things um that you can access for instance like the the the
through provider that was was sent to you people that got a binder two years ago it looks different
today because we updated things change things we changed the protocols things in life happen
if things in society happened that we had to change make different protocols for different things
so um they'll they'll will be anytime we update the binder the updated binder will be there and
i'm talking about the pages that are specific to you of course like your diet is specific to you but
the other pages um i also want to recommend that if you haven't seen already um there and i know
everybody's an information overload on ready so probably shouldn't say this but um my book on the
seven phases of detox is available as a download um for you on our website if you want to look at
that go back to our website look at books and this is the book it's called the seven phases of detoxification
it's not that long it's less than a hundred pages and it's um you could go through it and
say easy read but it talks about the reason why we do some of the make some of the recommendations that we
make that'll help you understand the physiology and some of the reasons why so that could be a good book
in my book on the mushrooms i finished as well um we're just yeah that's at the editors that hopefully
will be up in the next couple of months too so um my book on medicinal mushrooms so all right well
no other questions we will say goodnight for tonight i will probably do next week's zoom call as well
because um i made uh shall do a couple of row there when i was called last week so um i'll be
prayed for you uh we cherish your prayers for us as well and um if you need any further assistance
make sure you call and set it up with appointment with myself or Michelle as well all right love you all